if you were to arm a screenwriter with
one tool or weapon
in terms of screenwriting what would it
be uh
say imagination is to be have a flexible
mind to be willing to consider
alternatives to recognize that part of
the screenwriter's job is to
troubleshoot
and to problem solve and that creativity
and imagination
and the ability to say well you know i
don't have to set it in chicago
what if i said it in orlando florida
instead
what if what if it's a wonderful
tool to ask yourself what if instead of
being by the seaside it was in
we're in the mountains what if instead
of a porsche it were an old rattle trap
ford that reversal that flexibility of
thinking
is what's really important because
someone's going to get to the rewrite or
you're going to have a script consultant
or a director or a producer an actor say
it doesn't work what about
and you want your mind to be able to
move with that and for you to have an
open mind
but on the other hand not to just let
anyone
walk rampshot over your script because
there's a lot of people
that will read a script and want to
practice their own creativity
on your work he said you have to be
careful
but you also have to be open how would
we know someone like that
like how would we know the signs that
it's actually someone working out their
own
when when your gut goes
you know something usually gets roiled
up
that just doesn't feel right to you or
to your intention
for the script so sometimes somebody
comes along
and they say well what if instead of a
thriller we're and you say
no you know what i don't like and
so you have to
know that and it does take some time to
recognize
and it also takes some time to recognize
that sometimes when people
are are throwing out these ideas
they are recognizing a problem but they
don't know how to identify the problem
so one of the things is that problem
analysis even more than solution is
important
because most people when they
when they realize what the problem is
many times they can solve it
it's just they're kind of lost and you
do lose your objectivity
and it's hard i mean it is hard to find
your way many times
you